-Thank you. Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're here!
I love that energy.
Guys, we are coming at you
live from New York City,
where there's kind of
a heat wave happening.
It was 82 degrees out today.
82 in October.
On my way to work,
I saw a scarecrow in a Speedo.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-It was 82 and sweaty,
which is also how to describe
Episode 2 of "Golden Bachelor."
-Ooh!
-Some big news
from Washington today.
For the first time in history,
the House voted
to oust its speaker.
That's right.
After only
nine months on the job,
Kevin McCarthy has been removed
as speaker of the House.
Yeah, nine months.
Even Aaron Rodgers is like,
"Damn, that was fast."
Nine months? I've been to
Phish concerts longer than that.
Anyway, now that McCarthy's
run as speaker is over,
I thought it'd be fun
to take a look back
at his greatest moments
as Speaker of the House.
♪♪
-It was just...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, the other big story is
Trump's fraud trial
is under way.
And after his big day in court,
he posted -- This is real.
He posted this -- I know.
I have to say, "This is real,"
'cause a lot of people
won't believe that it's real.
It is real.
He posted a sketch of Jesus
sitting next to him
in the courtroom.
Take a look at this.
[ Laughter ]
When Jesus saw what he posted,
he said, "Oh, my dad."
[ Laughter ]
But did you see this yesterday?
Trump apparently had
a huge McDonald's order
delivered to the courthouse.
This is a photo of the delivery.
Look at it.
-Wow!
-That's not McDonald's delivery.
That's McDonald's luggage.
By the way, Trump eating
McDonald's is not really news,
I don't think.
Now, if Trump orders a
quinoa bowl from Sweetgreen --
that's news.
I think that would be...
But get this.
So, Trump complained
that it's unfair
that his trial
doesn't have a jury.
But the reason
it doesn't have a jury
is because his lawyers
never asked for one.
This is true.
To be fair, Trump can't have
a jury of his peers.
I mean, where are they going
to get 12 bankrupt
former reality-show hosts?
You know it's not good
when you're missing
the legal competence
of Rudy Giuliani.
You know what I'm saying?
Switching gears,
I saw that Paris
is dealing with a citywide
outbreak of bedbugs.
The deputy mayor saying,
"No one is safe."
And now President
Emmanuel Macron
is being urged to intervene.
In fact, he asked to appear
on our show tonight
to shed some light
on the crisis.
Mr. President,
the floor is yours.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Bonjour ♪
♪ It is me ♪
♪ There are bugs in Paris ♪
♪ That are bigger than fleas ♪
♪ And they make you itchy ♪
♪ They could be in your sheets ♪
♪ So check underneath ♪
♪ And if it were me ♪
♪ I wouldn't do Airbnb ♪
♪ Anywhere, they could creep ♪
♪ Even chest hair you see ♪
[ Crowd cheering ]
♪ So give it a clean ♪
♪ With a spritz of Febreze ♪
♪ But it is Fashion Week ♪
♪ Louis V and Gucci ♪
♪ Full of celebrity ♪
♪ Chalamet, Timothée ♪
♪ He is dating Kylie ♪
♪ And he plays Wonka, Willy ♪
♪ I love his movies ♪
♪ On the IMDb ♪
♪ But the bedbugs, O-M-G ♪
♪ They are really icky ♪
♪ Everywhere, they will be ♪
♪ Just like Swift and Kelce ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ But for now ♪
♪ I bid you adieu ♪
♪ Adieu, adieu ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you.
Emmanuel Macron, everybody.
He just ran off.
He ran away.
Bye.
-Oh, he's waving to you.
-He was waving to me.
-Oh!
-Isn't that nice of him?
-Oh, my gosh. And he sang.
-Oh, my gosh. Take care.
Guys, listen to this.
Delta Air Lines said
that they discovered
that some of their
aircraft engines had fake parts.
What?!
It's weird when you see parts
of your plane
being built on "Lego Masters."
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah, they looked inside
one of their planes
and found a guy just making
engine noises with his mouth.
[ Imitates engine revving ]
"Come on, Larry. Come on."
Yep, their planes had
a lot of fake parts,
which is why they're going
to be a new cast member
on "Real Housewives
of LaGuardia."
Some more business news.
Chipotle is testing a new robot
that can make burrito bowls
and salads.
It's not really that impressive.
It's just a ladle taped
to a pitching machine.
Well, guys, it's very good
to be here. It feels good.
This is our second show
back after we were on strike,
and it's so --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm happy to be here.
We were off the air
for over five months.
In the five months, I got into
grilling, I started a podcast.
Higgins,
what did you do this summer?
-I hit the picket lines,
went to Europe.
-Oh, good. That's good.
That's great.
How about you, Quest?
-We went on tour with LL Cool J.
-Oh, that's right.
That was awesome.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Cool.
How about you, James?
What'd you do this summer?
-I'm glad you asked, Jimmy.
My summer was totally tubular.
Not. Schwing!
I was looking forward
to seeing "Barbenheimer."
That's the last name
of my German
pen pal, Helga Barbenheimer.
But it turns out she isn't real.
I was being catfished by
the rude teens
who do donuts on my lawn.
-Alright.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But at least I became
fluent in German.
Get a load of this.
Oh, my gosh.
[ Speaking German ]
-What?!
-Oh, come...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Speaking German ]
-James, James, James,
are you okay, buddy?
-James isn't here today.
Exum disappearium.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The writers' strike hit
some of us
harder than others, I think.
Give it up for
James Poyser, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, this is wild.
A man in Slovakia was fined
after a traffic camera
caught his car speeding
with his dog behind the wheel.
Yeah, meanwhile, his owner was
in the back humping a pillow.
The dog was like,
"I've got to go get
to the matinee of 'Paw Patrol.'"
Hey, guys,
I read about a 77-year-old man
at a retirement community
in Florida
who is facing charges
for his stockpile
of illegal
erectile-dysfunction drugs.
Yeah, legal experts say he could
face a very stiff sentence.
-Whoa!
-If found guilty, he's looking
at 20 years of hard time.
-Aah!
-In court, the bailiff said,
"All rise,"
and the guy was like,
"Way ahead of you."
Alright.
Guys, finally, it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WePost."
Here we go.
-♪ WePost ♪
♪ WePost ♪
-Alright. Welcome.
Welcome to "WePost."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something
we should post on X.
I'm going to show you
five different posts,
and we're all going to vote
on whether you like
each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
You should at least.
If you don't, let us know,
and we'll get you one.
You can vote for all of these,
you can vote for none of them,
whatever you want,
and we'll see the results live.
Higgins, Roots,
you have clickers?
-Got it.
-Roots, you have clickers?
-We got 'em.
-Alright. Very good.
Whatever post gets
the most likes,
we will post it out
live on the show
so you can all like it
and we can "wepost" it.
It's like a shared experience.
You guys ready for this?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, good.
The first post is...
♪♪
-Wow!
-Again, the writers have been on
strike for north of five months.
Alright. It's interesting.
A lot of people have their
phones out during the concerts.
They don't watch
the show themselves.
-They just watch the thing.
-That's correct. Yeah.
So it's more of an observation
than a joke.
Sure. The votes are in.
Let's see the results here.
Wow!
[ Sad tuba, cymbal crash ]
Very honest,
very honest audience.
[ Laughter ]
Very honest tonight.
Okay.
This next one is...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
It's like walking on the moon.
-Uneven. They're not to code.
-I can't be the only one.
Let's see the results
right here.
[ Drumroll ]
Alright. A little bit better.
Alright, not bad.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I want to remind everyone,
these don't necessarily
get better.
[ Laughter ]
That's the thing
about this game.
That might be it.
-You don't know what's coming.
-I have no idea
if it's going to get better.
I don't know if it does.
-Ready?
-But let's try
this next one here.
This next one here says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Just see what happens.
-Yeah.
-"Hey, enough here for two."
Maybe you can tape
a concert with your phone, yeah.
-Alright, let's see the results.
I have a good feeling
about this one. Let's see.
Oh! That's good!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Just see what happens.
Why not?
Alright, let's go.
Next one up, it says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
They're all in the bed together.
-He's faking it.
-The whole room's a bed, right?
-Yeah.
Finds a golden ticket.
-You went yes?
-Yeah.
You go yes on all of them,
right?
-Yes, I do.
-Did you go yes
on that first one?
-Yes.
-Wow.
-I did not.
-That's interesting.
-You did not?
-No, I'm honest.
-You're honest. Yeah.
-Unless it gets in my way.
-He's honest
but he's very positive.
-Yeah.
-Did you go yes on that one?
-So, yeah, I went yes
on that one, as well.
-Yeah.
-It's pretty funny.
But I think the other one
is still --
-Might be better.
-I think the other one's better.
But let's see the results
on that one.
[ Drumroll ]
-Oh, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The other one? Other one still?
Yeah, the other one's
still in the lead.
Okay, good.
This is the last one here.
I think the other one
is going to take it.
-You think the --
-What was that one?
-184.
-No, not the --
What was the joke?
-The Uber.
-Uber.
-Oh, Uber Eats. Yeah.
Uber Eats is going to win.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah. There's no sense --
-Unless this one...
You never know.
-It's putting a lot of pressure
on this last one here.
-Well...
-I still think
it's going to be Uber.
-Okay.
-Uber Eats, but never know.
This last one says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Real.
-[ Imitating alarm blaring ]
Alright, get out, man!
-[ Laughing ]
-Okay.
Let's see the results
on this one. Here we go.
Oh! We have a winner!
There we go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
It is Uber Eats.
[ Dinging ]
"Wanna have fun?"
Uber Eats driver.
I'm going to post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like and enjoy.